ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
à suivre cet après-midi l'audition des
associations de victimes de la tempête
xynthia par la mission d'information de
communes du sénat sur les conséquences
de la tempête
hier les sénateurs ont entendu françois
baroin ministre du budget qui leur a
annoncé qu'une enveloppe de 450 millions
d'euros était prévu pour dédommager les
victimes tout de suite donc direction la
salle médicis bonne après midi a tous
voila merci encore une fois d'être
d'être ici
je voudrais au nom de de mes collègues
alors il ya un débat il ya une
commission ils sont tous ne sont pas là
malheureusement mais peu importe
mais je voudrais exprimer aux uns et aux
autres et notamment aux familles qui ont
eu à souffrir des disparitions notre
profonde sympathie et croyez bien que on
a commencé à travailler très vite qu'on
ménage pas notre peine on n'a pas de
baguette magique mais qu' on travaille
avec cette idée que l'on travaille pour
éviter que de tels drames ne se
reproduisent à l'avenir
donc c'est quelque chose qui nous habite
on fait pas seulement de la technique
sur le droit des sols sur
l'indemnisation sur les protections
digue lunaire et c'est en fait parce que
la technique on sait qu'on travaille
avec un objectif c'est faire en sorte
que des catastrophes comme ça et les
drames que vous avez pu connaître
ne sortons du spa l'avenir je voudrais
aussi vous remercier d'avoir accepté de
déplacer la la première entrevue la
première audition qui avait été prévu il
ya quelques il ya quelques semaines mais
il n'est pas toujours facile d'organiser
deux à la fois les travaux de la mission
de faire face aussi aux textes qui
viennent régulièrement au sénat et on
est dans une période où il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de tacles donc merci
encore une fois de votre compréhension
et encore une fois je suis très heureux
que on consacre ce moment à
l'explication à votre vécu et aux pistes
que vous souhaitez nous donner je
voudrais aussi vous dire qu on est dans
cette salle pascal est un peu importante
mais c'est une salle où on a des
captations derrière devant à côté qui
permettent de renvoyer la captation sur
public sénat et surtout sur le en
enregistrement et sur le site en direct
internet qui est assez qui est très
consulté en direct donc je voudrais pour
vous prendre en traître
si je veux dire vous le rappelez vous
adresser à nous mais en même temps un
public plus vaste que celui qui était
dans la salle écouté alors ce que je
vous propose dans un premier temps
peut-être celle de faire un
un tour de table pour que chacun puisse
se présenter présenter sur tous vos
communes d'origine
et puis ensuite je vous laisse tout de
suite la parole pour que vous puissiez
alors dans l'ordre comme on est beaucoup
pas comment on va faire mais peut-être
secteur par secteur
1 mais peut-être que dans un premier
temps je vous laisse vous présentez nous
puissions est ouvert olivier schmitt je
suis président de l'association pour la
sauvegarde du site de boyardville
notre association représentera 1200
adhérents pour sauver boyardville la
perrotine et saint trojan frêche c'est
l'île d'oléron
j'ai prévu dans bonjour de soul et
jean-luc hilmar je représente
l'association vivre à fouras la fumée à
fouras la fumée nous avons deux zones
encore une jaune et les zones d'attentes
qui est une zone orange nous nous
battons bien évidemment vous en doutez
pour que cette zone orange font pas sont
jaunes
des documents dans ce sens savoir m je
connais donc bonjour michel le bozec
président de l'association de sauvegarde
du village des boucholeurs
donc vous avez pu visiter d'ailleurs en
orange toujours pardon de zones oranges
où rick et une grande zone orange dont
qui dirait stress les gens donc
l'association nous sommes à peu près
mille trois cents personnes entre les
adhérents les donateurs et nous nous
battons bien sûr pour ce que vous savez
quoi bonjour monsieur présidence pierre
borel du collectif des sinistrés de
l'île de ré donc moi je suis sur la
commune de luri mais on représente
également la commune à la flotte-en-ré
vous êtes résident principal résidents
quand on sait par exemple principal
président principal et vous représentez
il ya quatre communes sur l'île de ré
oui oui mais les communes qui sont en
zone jaune n'ont pas souhaité et ce
qu'ils se manifester ce qu'est
compensées ou ceux qui n'ont pas eux non
plus ne nous ont pas reçu
donc on sait voilà merci président et
plaisir on va vous donner l'alerté avoué
daniel havis président bonjour je
représente l'association d'entre aide
aux sinistrés de port des barques
ce que nous souhaitons lors de cette
réunion c'est pouvoir faire accélérer
les décisions
j'ai croisé le maire ce matin tout à
fait dans le sens de l'établissement en
revanche d'un zonage oui disons
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons un zonage
jaune et un zonage noir ils virent
effectivement un certain nombre de
familles sinistrées qui sont en zone
jaune qui souhaiteraient effectivement
rallier la zone noire voilà merci
alors on passait en sont un exemple
jours xavier machuron mandard donc
de l'association à vif représentants des
victimes des communes de
la-faute-sur-mer et de
l'aiguillon-sur-mer donc le camp vous
savez dans ces deux communes
il ya eu des dégâts absolument important
et malheureusement un nombre de victimes
tout à fait
je dirais traumatisant dix ans compte
tenu des circonstances des faits donc
compte tenu de la complexité aussi de la
situation à travers les zones dont on
connaît la difficulté à comprendre la
pertinence il ya un certain nombre de
deux points en effet que l'on abordé et
puis il existe encore des problèmes je
dirais humains qui sont largement
non non non traitées pour le moment il
faut aussi penser aux vécus et au au
quotidien des personnes qui n'ont pas
encore je dirais de deux solutions à
leurs problèmes immédiats
on repasse en charente maritime
charon aux gens ce président thierry de
mag je représente l'association
reconstruire charron la commune de
charron 238 familles sinistrées en zone
noire dont 200 qui souhaitent être
indemnisées 27 qui contestent pour toute
difficulté d'attendre problème humain de
angoisses de dépression et un problème
spécifique à charron qui concerne
l'urbanisation avec l'établissement
public foncier régional dont la lenteur
est incompatible avec l'urgence des
sinistrés d'accord pour d'accord pour
m'en reparlerez ça parce que on a pour
l'instant c'est un point qu'on a pas
trop étudié donc si jamais je pose pas
la question vous me faites penser un peu
monsieur le président bonjour et jean
deregnaucourt sinistrés le 28 février
jour de mon anniversaire
à la faute-sur-mer heureusement pour moi
j'avais une double résidence
donc j'ai connu le cilice le jour même
et j'ai pu m'en échapper j'ai bien dit
mon échappée le jour-même aussi donc on
comptera dans les détails après
bonjour alors je suis mireille guillet
je représente la femme les familles de
victimes j ai perdu ma maman et je
déplore l'indifférence dans laquelle
nous vivons en tant que familles de
victimes
vous me poserez plus de questions tout à
l'heure si vous voulez mais on est
vraiment dans la différence mais vous
pouvez vous exprimer vous même sens que
je vous pose des questions si vous les
choses sur le coeur
au contraire il faudra le dire monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs bonjour
eric racofier résidents secondaires à la
faute sur mer
de par ma formation à but scientifique
j'essaye de comprendre comment on a pu
en arriver là
je suis vos recommandations très
attentivement et je vais essayer de
surveiller pour qu' une telle
catastrophe ne puisse pas se reproduire
si c'est pas l'indiscret vous vous êtes
ingénieur de kehl en génie de
l'environnement en génie d'environnement
à atteindre
bon c'est intéressant vers le jury
chimiques mais ils ont je me souviens de
quelques cours sur la la dynamique des
rivières et ma foi je me reproche à moi
aussi d'en avoir vu des choses sans
réellement les noter et maintenant que
la catastrophe est arrivée parce qu'on a
une culture du risque et nul
malheureusement en france 2 sur ce
moment on pourra reparler mais pas que
ça si le président bonjour mesdames et
messieurs bonjour raymond roux chirol
nom du causse et démonstrations de la
vis la faute sur mer l'aiguillon et
président de la commission zone noire
puisque
dans l'embouchure du lait nous comptons
trois zones noires une première peu sur
la faute sur mer et les deux autres qui
suit situe du côté de l'aiguillon sur
mer la clé en main des caves dans un
premier temps et ensuite la pointe les
tableaux je suis je vous remercie de nos
accueillant sur le président de ces
zones noires n'ont subi aucune
modification
et si je pouvais témoigner de
l'incohérence et du sentiment
d'injustice que ressentent les fautes et
je pourrais vous donner des chiffres des
hommes des maisons non touchés ou très
faiblement touchés et inversement des
maisons quasiment atteint dénonce homme
noir et si nous pouvions nous expliquer
sur ce point là merci très bien alors
pour que chacun puisse pouvoir
s'exprimer quel est ce que quelqu'un
souhaite commencer ou es ce que vous
avez entre vous alors il ya deux
commandes et ria géante maritime et on a
des problématiques qui sont différentes
en charente maritime et en vendée c'est
un peu plus cohérent ne serait ce que
parce que les associations couvre les
deux parties du tarif du lait en fait si
bien l'aiguillon que sur la faute qui
souhaitent commencer
moi monsieur le président je veux bien
commencé moi je pense qu'on est venus là
c'est en commun c'est surtout pour
aborder la partie sociale donc trois
mois après la tempête
j'ai dit à quelques journalistes pour
moi il ya eu un phénomène exceptionnel
dans xynthia mais très peu de temps
après il ya un autre phénomène et
xynthia 2 qui est la tempête
départementale qui au bout de trois mois
est en train de rendre les gens malades
stressé des passages à l'hôpital des
arts et du vin des commandes ird et du
par le stress des malles des maladies
cardiovasculaires et puis les gens avec
cette fameuse zone orange
il n'en peut plus quoi ils ont peu plus
ils sont malades donc il faut essayer de
faire quelque chose moi je pense que les
dégâts sont plus considérable avec
xynthia 2 qu'avec cynthia qu'on a connus
qui n'a duré que quelques heures
qu'est ce que vous dit l'état
aussi bien la préfecture que
il y aussi secrétaires d'état qu'est ce
qu'on vous a dit sur l'échéance où on
saura si les boucholeurs passe en zone
d'acquisition amiable ou resto en zone
jaune de prescription qui serait qu est
ce qu on a eu une réunion avec jean
lyonnais tant que porte-parole de la
mission parlementaire lundi dernier au
soir pour les doucheurs il a annoncé
d'ici une quinzaine de jours donc là on
arrive en fin de semaine donc je pense
que fin de semaine prochaine on sera
fixé donc qu'est ce qu'ils voulaient
donner des éléments est ce que n'ont pas
spécialement à écouter les gens déjà
sont attentifs et où il faut pas donné
d'éléments giral ce niveau-là mauvais ou
bon c'est tout un village entier qui
nous on est 99 % à vouloir rester donc
pour l'instant tant qu'il n'y aura pas
de défaut de résultats définis définitif
je dirais et vaut mieux attendre encore
une semaine de plus et après agir quoi
est-ce que vous avez vu alors ça c'est
vrai ça tout le monde ne peuvent pas
demander à annoncer une mission pour les
expertises complémentaires pour préparer
le dossier est de le dossier d' enquête
publique est ce que vous avez vu sur le
terrain des signes de cette mission
temporaire en chambre maritime d'abord
et puis ensuite je en vendée après je ne
sais pas au niveau de mes collègues mes
amants boucholeurs pour l'instant on n'a
pas vu de signes il n'y a pas eu
d'annoncé est ce qui est des experts
importe qui sont nationaux
départementaux qui sont passés ce que
vous auriez repérer des par exemple
est-ce que vous avez vu des experts
géomètre pour uys ça on a vu tout le
monde a vu je pense dans le département
je moi j'appelle pas ça des experts
j'appelle ça des gens qui viennent
constater des hauteurs d'eau qu'il y a
eu dans les rues ou dans les maisons
mais une personne ne veut se pose-t-on
la question pourquoi il ya eu c'est tout
et c'est là où le c'est grave puisqu'on
constate un niveau d'eau mais personne
ne se pose la question pourquoi y ait du
ceto et tout le monde sait très bien
c'est qu'il ya un manque d'entretien des
digues des défenses de côtes et qu'il
manque une digue sur le terrain du
conservatoire voilà le principal
ça c'est à qui il a quand même oui c'est
acquis mais on a reçu on a reçu le
président du conservatoire ici
quelques semaines on avait posé la
question et c'est vrai les choses là
dessus cette protection lava va s'ériger
voilà notre état qui donc les études
sont lancées déjà au jour d'aujourd'hui
les études sont lancées
donc on va dire que dans un an et demi
l'enquêté sera terminée et les travaux
pourront démarrer d'accord là juste pour
les vendeurs passe en vendée pour la
même question est-ce que vous avez vu
des experts ont la faute hier il y avait
une réunion ce matin à la mairie de la
faute sur mer avec qui avec voilà voilà
monsieur monsieur pitié donc mais on
n'en sait les délégués à la solidarité
donc la demande l union avec les
représentants des associations
on n'en sait pas plus pour l'instant
d'accord allez-y monsieur oui messieurs
forêts dont une concernant fouras alors
en deux mots ce que je n'ai pas dit tout
à l'heure four à la zone orange concerne
104 maison il ya 87 résidences
secondaires et 17 résidences principales
nous avons organisé des réunions et jean
louis léonard et sylvie marcilly notre
maire de fort armes pour essayer de
savoir ce que depuis le 8 avril date à
laquelle le des cartes sont parues sur
le site de la préfecture
nous avons jamais reçu de courrier
jamais d'autres informations que celles
qu'on va chercher nous mêmes à cette
date jean louis borloo avait signalé que
l'on devrait connaître le sort des zones
à expertiser dite orange dans les quinze
jours
nous sommes maintenant bientôt nous
sommes le 10 juin
aucune réponse à ce jour on n'est qu'à
celles le délai de 15 jours que le votre
homologue
des boucholeurs annonce est ce que ça
vous a été aussi pour fouras annoncé
nous avons quinze jours enfin vu
pratiquement 8 10 jours quand même c'est
à dire que toutes les semaines on nous
annonce que dans 15 jours nous seront
vraisemblement fixée alors les quinze
jours prochains nous attendons je
voulais vous rappeler que c'est ce que
le maire est ce que madame le maire a
été contacté est-ce qu'elle a eu des
contacts notamment avec des experts je
vous savez sort elle a eu un contact
avec des experts très récemment convoqué
par monsieur le préfet henri masse qui
étaient des experts pour aider notre
mère a redynamisé des secteurs qui
seraient vouées à la destruction
donc elle s'est opposée nous la
remercions à nouveau sur ce type de
procédure puisqu'elle considère que nous
n'avons pas de zona en démolition
potentiel aujourd'hui les seules
informations que nous ayons eue c'est
via un article paru dans le parisien où
on expliqué dans un encart que des
experts allaient venir la semaine
suivante en charente maritime qui ferait
étude au cas par cas
ce à quoi on avait demandé à monsieur
léonard et à notre mère de bien vouloir
nous informer des dates parce que s'il
doit y avoir des études parcellaire il
nous semblait cohérent que les
propriétaires puissent être prévenues
pour ouvrir des maisons constaté des
terrains des auteurs enfin un que
sais-je et elle n'était absolument pas
au courant et certains voisins m'ont
prévenu qu' effectivement ils ont vu
passer un expert une une demi-journée
vraisemblement sur la pointe de la fumée
et qui demandaient des hauteurs d'eau
dans certaines maisons points mais
madame le maire n'était pas au courant
de la venue de ces experts comme à vire
aussi vis à vis d'autres choses à
peut-être handball tout à l'heure oui
bien allez-y verront pas des wampas
rallye dirt et en heure d'essais de
calais apprend passera un deuxième sujet
oui monsieur président bien coûter en ce
qui concerne l'île d'oleron nous n'avons
reçu aucun courrier depuis le mois de
février
nous n'avons aucun document et nous
n'avons vu personne y compris sur les
jaunes y compris sur les zones noires
rouges
solidarité nous envie parce que en
revendait les lettres qui ont été à
nostra tive qui a été expédiée nous
n'avons pas de l'être
cardon rien aux champs dès le 8 avril
une fois que nous n'avons absolument
aucun courrier comme évidemment les
autres la solidarité de ses silos n'ont
aucun expert n'est passée sur le terrain
on le fait on l'aurait vu parce que en
février mars nous sommes très peu
nombreux dans la voix hier vie nous
sommes 90 donc quelqu'un avec un client
sur votre de suite
neuf personnes nous avons écrit à
monsieur borloo ou qu'une réponse notre
député écrit à monsieur pour nous avec
notre courrier pas traquer roulage les
députés c'est qui fait maxime votre nom
s'écrit je parle et leurs obligés quand
un ac didier quentin avec les maires les
trois maires et le président la comédie
de communes ont écrit à monsieur borloo
pas de réponse
nous sommes pour l'instant dans un avis
de plus complet le plus complet alors
effectivement il ya des commissaires
enquêteurs qui devrait venir
effectivement veut faire une analyse cas
par cas il aux parigots ce qui nous
arrangerait bien on verrait départ
quelqu'un mais surtout c'est je suis
avec mon collègue tout à fait la course
de côte et sociale qui nous inquiète
parce que des personnes habiles témoin
et la perrotine ce sont des gens qui
sont pas des nantis qui sont des
retraités et qu'ils savent pas où aller
puisqu'il ya plus de terrain tous - tout
le moins pas sur l'île d'oléron et ils
n'ont aucune information mais
strictement aucune information ne sont
aujourd'hui payés une réunion publique
j'imagine à
aboya alors il est revenu au public où
le monsieur très faibles se massent donc
à exposer on c'est en mars avril la
fameuse zone noire qui c'était la veille
je pense du déplacement de la mission
chant price a fait le 13 ou 14 avril je
crois je me souviens d'accord pour nous
les zones noires n'existe pas puisqu'il
n'y a pas de fondement légal
le félin de mots c'est un référé le
tribunal de poitiers de la rappeler
comme vous le savez du coup oui alors
donc oui alors sur la soie l'île de ré
celui-ci des spécificités je vais pas
vous les savez je pense oui
voilà donc sinon non sur loup on n'a
toujours reçu aucun courrier nominatif
officiel depuis la tempête d'appareils
dream public
non non c'était personnel c'était le
maire qui nous avait convoqué chacun
opto d'abord par téléphone avant la
publication sur internet le soir ils
nous ont téléphoné pour nous dire que ça
les a pas respectées ce travail oui sa
lumière divine venir nous a téléphoné
quand nous a pour nous informer avant
que ça paraisse dans le médian ryad
maison il ya là des maisons en zone
noire
19 on sait pas parce que la légende des
sur l'une d'entre elles on au quai on
sait toujours pas mentionné en noir ou
blanc des cas donc aucun aucun courrier
officiel un manque d'informations la
russie enfin la semaine dernière à
recevoir le délégué de solidarité
monsieur maillot qui nous avait dit de
vente surprise qui avait eu aucune étude
et aucune mesure réalisée sur notre
commune que pour l'établissement du
zonage ils sont déterminés à la
municipalité qui aavait veut qu'ils
avaient eux ont fait remonter les
informations que ces maisons étaient
apparemment celle qui était en zone en
danger avéré deux mois ce qui n'est pas
forcément le cas quand on voit ce qu'il
ya eu sur même dans notre commune qui
sont actuellement dans une zone qui est
en zone orange et par exemple vous avez
vu combien de quelle hauteur d'eau donc
on a fait un constat d'huissier on a
différentes hauteurs d'eau selon selon
les pièces de la maison on a eu 35 dans
le sens d'un extérieur ou plus au 73 à
63 cm en tout cas moins d'un mètre dans
la maison 35 centimes et dans une pièce
46 danger nous avait 53
vous avez une vache de protection en à
un étage mon à un étage là vous avez une
zone refuge d'accord et vous avez donné
à 509 au quick digues ou à lattes
hérault bien trop rêver à sa 100 m ouais
elle a été reconstruite cette digue
depuis déjà un mois et demi et bien sûr
avec fortis avec consolidé forte chez le
problème celui des métiers c'est une
digue de front de mer sending cessé de
nous on sait le fier d'ars il est donc
nécessaire ça me fâche pas comment on
est fiers sa commune chaque terroir les
exonère c'est pas de la plénière passé
une baisse et un filet quand ça rentre
sandrine n'y a pas à part la tente
pendant la tempête c'est un endroit très
calme quand ya pas de vagues
il ya donc tout a été reconstruit en
digue sur ma commune est née sur l'île
de ré en général bien sûr il manque
encore quelques mais il manque encore
quelques quelques détails à fortifier
mais le problème de protection
il y en a pu quoi vu que ça a été
réparée donc on comprend pas pourquoi
ils veulent expropriés alors qu'ils ont
déjà protégé ça serait une double
dépense à nos yeux quoi jug ils ont ils
sont protégés quand dirigent ils ont ils
ont bouché les trous où ils ont conforté
chez nous on refait la digue entièrement
parce que la digue était à la douleur t
elle été emportées vu qu'elle était il
en direct en contact enfin je veux dire
plus haut de plus grande et il aurait
aussi à quelle hauteur vous avez pas su
j'ai demandé one au maire va le compte
rendu des travaux qualité compte
effectuer sur l'île de ré mais je n'ai
pas encore odile aurais je n'ai pas
encore reçu
ok donc et puis on a quand même choqué a
sur l'île de ré la différence de
traitement quoi selon les communes mais
est seulement l'île de ré voulait dire
au sein de l'os selon les communes parce
que ce sont des dix communes lhid aurait
bien eu il ya eu une 9
il ya eu neuf communes ont été inondées
sinistrés sur les disques est sûre
libéré et on se retrouvera devant honore
la flotte et lois en sachant qu'il ya
d'autres communes qui ont eu plus de
dégâts et qui n'ont pas de zonage du
tout alors on est content que l'état
s'occupe de notre sécurité à nous c'est
bizarre qui s'occupe pas de la sécurité
des autres personnes si quoi on comprend
pas surtout plus grande que cette
situation va vous redévelopper le schéma
de l'île de ré du principe contraire là
il ya vraiment une injustice de
traitement entre les différentes zones
de la charente-maritime loi qu'on
connaît tous parce qu'on est tous
charente et loi c'est une presqu'île qui
s'avance dans le fier d'ars
l'île de ré a retrouvé sa configuration
du 12ème siècle au moment de la tempête
en trois à quatre îlots voilà il ya des
zones qui ont été submergées à plus d'un
mètre 80 quand je dis des zones c'est à
dire des secteurs pour lesquels il n'y a
pas de zonage du taux c'est la raison
pour laquelle on s'étonne quand même
fortement que le lobbying et les pus la
pression est plus perdre à être
délaissés on vous dit la flotte-en-ré
alain closier rien dit
attention la ville at on a eu les deux
morts il ya eu deux morts à la
flotte-en-ré c2c de personnes dans cette
zone à l'est en jaune c'est la zone du
port du port de la flotte
par contre les olives noires et des
zones de refuge vous avez un étage oui
oui et les autres maisons inondées les
met toutes les maisons quasiment avait
un étage pendant celle qui se tendra à
part une ou deux sur les listes la
réponse du préfet m'a c'est que l'île de
ré a été inondée alors que l'île
d'oléron a été submergée non ils nous
ont dit aussi qu elle avait été
submergée
non mais du changement submergé on la
comprend plus donc là il se réfère aux
critères de cinétique de le délégué de
la déléguée de solidarité nous a dit
qu'on n'aurait pas dû être données nous
vu les dégâts qu'on avait il pourrait y
pour elle et pour elle mettre par écrit
je je je vais c'est dû demander qu'on
était défendable et qu'il avait demandé
une expertise contradictoire pour lui
demander de vous confirmer ça vous lui
demandez tout confirmé sa part écrit et
si vous avez un écrit vous me verrez vos
douleurs verrez aucun accord globalement
les délégués à la solidarité
j'en profite pour poser cette question
c'est ça une utilité qu'est-ce qu'ils
font vous les voyez comment comme vous
voulez ressentez nous en resterons pour
notre part nous ont rassurés sur toutes
les questions d'assurance positive team
has more d'ailleurs il ya eu un contact
humain en fait vous avez vu quelqu'un
saurait lui en était simple erreur enfin
de voir quelqu'un qui était très
agréable mais qui avait pas beaucoup
d'éléments pas par sa foi qui plus est
vous ici
ils se sont intéressés plus à
l'indemnisation vous dit
pour pour nous non non il nous a
informés sur les différents choix qu'on
en avait devant nous l'accord donc soit
soit d'accepter l'indemnisation soit e
contester le zonage sur ce qu'on avait
déjà fait
est-ce qu'il vous en reparler de cette
mission tant porte de cette expérience
et expertise complémentaire de terrain
il en a parlé ou paris - a parlé de
toute façon nous n'y a pas eu d'
expertise du tout suffit il vous a dit
quand même qu'ils allaient je vous passe
tout de suite la machine
il vous a dit qu'il y avait
expertises en cours où il y en avoir a
dit qu'il allait elle est solide nous
l'avait sollicité une expertise
contradictoire pour ceux qui le
souhaitaient pas j'ai la pression sur
ces filières que des photos après je
reprends le film et sur le sur ce sujet
large sur surfer villégier de délégués à
la solidarité et d'experts en fait
qu'ils sont liés
si vous vous souvenez lors de votre
visite en charente maritime les 14 avril
nous avions collectivement tous mis en
avant notre
notre façon à cette date nous étions
choqués de l'inéquité de manque de
transparence et d'inhumanité dans le
comportement des pouvoirs publics
vis-à-vis de toutes les familles de
sinistrés et plus particulièrement ce
qui concernait les zonages et nous
demandions que soit reconsidérée les
zonages avec de véritables experts qui
viennent sur les lieux des sinistres en
présence des sinistrés pour mesurer la
réalité du sinistre en fait c'est
simplement une approche concrète et
réaliste de la situation
ce que nous avons réclamé depuis le
début les pouvoirs publics ont considéré
qu' il apporterait la réponse en
déléguant des délégués à la solidarité
qui sont des personnes qui ont des
compétences mais qui n'ont pas la
compétence du zonage ils ne sont pas
compétents ils ne sont pas experts pour
vers leur travail le travail que nous
leur demandons et donc ils sont hors
sujet nous n'avons toujours pas la
réponse mais qu'est ce qui est invisible
ou où il avait rencontré par exemple
alors moi je connais très bien madame
simon chang et au délégué à l'eau et à
la solidarité qui se chargent de charron
qui fait un travail attentif de délégués
à la solidarité je ne lui reproche pas
de bien faire son travail de délégués à
la solidarité
ce que je déplore et comme tous mes
collègues du département c'est que nous
n'ayons toujours pas d'experts qui est
la compétence pour travailler sur le
zonage un délégué à la solidarité n'a
pas la compétence la saison
on ne mangerait clamant nous réclamons
cela depuis le début et nous comprenons
pas alors les les pouvoirs publics nous
dit mais le travail a été bien fait si
ce travail avait été bien fait les
experts n'auraient pas peur de venir
présenter le travail qu'il considère
avoir bien fait nous n'avons rencontré
personne n'avons absolument aucun
interlocuteur et cela nous continuons de
dire que c'est inéquitable que ce n'a
pas que ça manque de transparence et que
c'est inhumain nous disons la même chose
qu il y a deux mois
mais en ce qui le concerne le délégué à
la solidarité a rencontré peu de
sinistrés puisque les sinistrés de l'île
d'oléron ont demandé à notre association
de les représenter
si fait que parce qu'il considérait que
monsieur monsieur maillot en
l'occurrence n'est pas leur apporter de
solution et que rencontre et ne portait
pas d'autres informations que celles que
on leur avait donné donc monsieur
maillot a téléphoné au propriétaire des
résidences secondaires partout en france
vouloir dire que pour les pousser à
vient expertise et leurs maisons cela
sinon il y avait exproprié à sion et
c'est là un point essentiel chez nous
c'est que il ya une pression très
importante très très importante des
domaines qui vont très vite pour faire
des propositions de rachat amiable il ce
mardi 6h à l'amiable après venaient plus
de procédures plus du pct i semble que
les autres équipes de délégués à la
solidarité met pas la même pression en
raion nous là nous de la pression très
importante très très incohérente
alors balayé la vendée
un problème de communication et
d'explication aussi pour l'existence
même de ces délégués à la solidarité
parce que par moments on en a pas
véritablement vu la trace et c'est un
problème pour que l'on découvre n'y a
pas de pression
il n'y a pas de délégués comment ça
vient pas d'elle mais vous
personnellement où tout le monde il ya
des délégations et des rites et en
trompant vendée en tout cas on ne l'a
pas vraiment les à communication de
manière claire les deux vitesses qui
sont efficaces autant qu'à faire
ça traduit le sk je creuse au terme des
procédures non mais moi on rappelait on
va l'appeler rapidement la fin aurait
appelé pour savoir nous indiquer qu'il y
avait des dégâts sur les vérités que je
dis partout
comment se serait-il manifester monsieur
non mais je rêve je sens qu'on parlera
mais c'est comme ça c'est tout
enchantement et de vitesse dans ce média
on a l'impression c'est à dire qu'en
charente maritime notamment à aytré où
il y avait quarante et une maisons en
zone noire il y a eu des propositions
qui ont été faites par france domaine
qui sont des propositions financières
très alléchante très alléchante qui sont
largement au-dessus du prix réel des
maisons j'ai des contacts fréquents avec
marie olivia rocca qui représente
l'association des sinistrés est
clairement des maisons qui a été proposé
un certain prix sont évalués par les
domaines 20 à 30% au-dessus c'est un
point sur lequel on va on va revenir un
simplement je m'étonne gère deux jours
donné la parole mais je m'étonne
contrairement à membres assurés s'il
faut j'irai sur le terrain j'étais
l'autre jour ces agriculteurs
il ya deux jours
pour les histoires des digues s'il faut
gérer ce week end je sais pas quand
j'irai rencontrer sur place et délayé à
s'arrêter pour pour constater de juger
le problème est parce que il y en nous
indiquant place voilà on a on n'a pas
d'explication
le délégation vérité c'est un travail de
médiation je sais pas si vous êtes
d'accord avec moi qu'on peut traduire
d'explication de prise en compte de
difficultés alors que cela peut aller de
l'indemnisation
ils n'ont pas de compétences de zonage
ils vont simplement vous dire expliquer
les choses dont je crois que ça peut
être utile sur un certain nombre de
pistes mais ce sont plutôt des
médiateurs qui sont là pour pour
expliquer pour avoir un contact pour
prendre en compte une partie de la
souffrance et l'explication des
différentes procédures
c'est plutôt ça que sur le zonage je
sais pas si je trahissais ce que vous
vivez vous charles proactive mais
franchement non mais je suis sûr que je
ne peux pas penser qu'il n'y a pas de
délai gascon mais qu'on veut pas dire
c'est pas il ya des délégués sur les
rites et c'est pas possible autrement
quand même alors si je vous parlais tout
à l'heure qu'on avait l'impression tant
que familles de victimes puisque moi
j'ai eu le plus gros gros dégâts qui
puisse exister puisque je n'ai plus ma
maman maman je pense qu'elle aurait pu
être là s'il y avait eu des choses de
faites auparavant
et là vous parlez délégués à la
solidarité je vais vous donner un
exemple tout à l'heure je disais qu'on
existait page et je n'ai eu aucun mot de
condoléance que ce soit du maire de la
faute du conseil général 2 de qui que ce
soit de quiconque à part du maire de ma
petite ville voilà du maire des neiges
il m'a écrit à deux reprises à lui merde
des douches à l'automne voilà monsieur
perrin à titre personnel puisqu'il
connaissait bien ma maman et moi même
mais aucune condoléances officielles
ça fera pas revenir ma maman mais nous
on essaye de nous cacher depuis un mois
j'ai écrit à monsieur de villiers
j'ai reçu
un coup de fil de secrétariat la semaine
dernière en disant on a bien pris vote
demande en considération vous écrira on
sait pas si ce sera l'unique qu'elle
demande ou un rendez vous je demandais à
le rencontrer
voilà trois mois et demi après j'ai
toujours rencontré personne je pense
qu'on dérange sérieusement je suis sur
le jeu comprend parfaitement la peine
que vous ressentez il ya eu et le
premier ministre même s'est déplacé le
mage allusion aux familles des victimes
c'était en même temps que la sépulture
de ma maman j'étais à ma maman je
comprends voilà c'est exactement la même
mais bon il ya des indélicatesses train
là l'état l'état la municipalité
beaucoup d'indélicatesse mollahs j'ai
même reçu un recommandé de la mairie de
la faute au nom de ma maman ça fait très
mal
voilà je pense qu'elle est même décédée
sur leur commune voilà donc non
seulement n'existe pas mais la banderole
des victimes qui est retirée par la
municipalité cinq jours après si ça
c'est pas un affront excusez moi il ya
un moment où faut réagir il ya un moment
où des victimes en auront marre donc
pensé 1 2 finale où je suis pas seule il
y en ad'autres je parle au nom des
familles des 29 victimes
c'est ce que j'ai dit à l'introduction
on ne peut pas comment dirais-je je vois
bien le sentiment de révolte que vous
pouvez trouver c'est parfaitement
naturel
mais on essaie de nous à notre niveau
aussi du maître de mettre le meilleur de
nous-mêmes pour essayer de comprendre
les causes pour essayer d'apporter des
réponses alors dominé par faire et parmi
les réponses qu'on proposera vous aurez
sans doute des choses à redire parce que
voilà mais je vous assure que quand on
travaille sur cette mission on est je
vous l'assuré
en tout cas à titre personnel qu'on est
habité par ce sentiment qu'il y a des
gens des êtres humains qui sont passés
de l'autre côté et qui a aujourd'hui les
familles dont la vie est brisée et dans
la vie ne sera plus jamais demain comme
et et hier je vous rassure c'est pas
seulement encore une fois un problème
technique un problème administratif
je sais que c'est dépend probablement
alors je reviens sur les alizés monsieur
sur le poste de délégué solidarité où
nous permettent de rajouter
effectivement après sur ce point des
victimes est en totale cohérence est
d'accord avec ce qui a été dit
préalablement sur les personnes qui
actuellement vivent aussi sous une halle
un stress qui est une permanente
oscillation entre espoir et désespoir
au gré je dirais des annonces
médiatiques
qui sont quand même qui s'étirait on
parlait d' affront tout à l'heure c'est
aussi quelque chose qui est quand même
très dur à vivre pour tout le monde
puisque les gens ne savent plus du tout
quoi faire quelle quel espoir avoir dans
l'avenir
donc c'est une attitude c'est la
situation quand même très très
très dommageable et on espère quand même
que il n'ya pas mais des annonces
médiatiques vont plutôt dans enfin elles
sont parties de bouchra rien le
périmètre des zones et son périmètre
définitif à des choses où les choses ont
bougé au cas par cas et c'est au nom de
la communication fait la différence sur
et qu'on a on avait souvent fait
remonter et on a dénoncé ici un certain
nombre de cacophonie au haut niveau
notamment ministériel et parfois au sein
de grands ministères et entre des
ministres qui sont censés se parler pour
nombre est bien au courant de la
situation mais vous ne vous n'avez pas
vu comme président le deck de deux
délégués non non non non c'est
complètement fou actuellement en vendée
on n'a pas d'explication sur le mode de
fonctionnement du budget fait j'aimerais
quand même parce que je le prie de
parole depuis tout à l'heure et puis les
i donc je voudrais revenir sur le report
des bas alors par l'équipement des
situations en situation un petit peu de
temps à l'envers un petit cadeau puisque
la réclamation aujourd'hui que l'on a
c'est effectivement de qu'il y ait un
peu plus de zonage noir enfin vous savez
qui hier j'étais environ
parce que sir de la gironde et
potentiellement extrêmement extrêmement
dangereux encore plus que l'espère du
lait ou d'autres cette ligne air de la
coupe
j'ai enfin tim est là bas il ya quarante
maisons mais sur l'e40 je pense qu'il ya
une dizaine et on on va se bat pour que
puisse faire l'objet d'une disposition
prévue par le parlement la loi barnier
95 fonds barnier en gironde que ce que
je voulais dire c'est que effectivement
il y a eu aujourd'hui sur port des
barques de 17 maisons déconsidéré en
zone noire
bon c'était une sont des maisons qui
sont dans une cuvette donc effectivement
il n'y a pas de il n'ya pas revenir les
photos reçues
maintenant il y a d'autres maisons qui
sont dans d'autres zones de port des
barques qui l'a les maisons sont
classées en zones où il y a eu quand
même plus de 1 mètre d'eau chez des
personnes très âgées handicapées
certaine dans des lits médicalisés qui
ont été à la limite de passer
effectivement de l'autre côté ce qui
avait plus de courant non plus pour
remonter lit donc là effectivement il y
à toute une zone effectivement où il
faut qu'il y ait une nouvelle étude
de fait et dans cette zone toutes ces
maisons elles ont d etat joue pas donc
justement ce sont toutes des maisons de
plain-pied tout et tout
il y appelle et aide à combien il y en a
à peu près une trentaine entre 25 et 30
effectivement bon il y en a peut-être
qui sont construites un petit peu plus
sur elle avec les autres et qui auront
eu trente ou quarante centimètres de moi
mais c'est une zone qui est à
reconsidérer et pour laquelle elle est
finalement est-ce que ça je m'adresse
collectivement la et parents vous avez
terminé ou non vous avez des
allez-y non mais déterminer si c'est
terminé que je que je souhaite surtout
c'est que la commission essaie de faire
accélérer le mouvement
pour que ces gens là qui aujourd'hui
sont à la limite de passer à l'acte
suicidaire parce que ces gens là
aujourd'hui sont relativement âgés et
handicapés etc
il faut à tout prix qu'on arrive à faire
quelque chose pour ces gens là qui sont
dans une zone à très haut risque
d'accord portant un mot vous disiez il
ya deux minutes que vous faisiez
référence aux gouvernements qui semblait
s'adoucir sur sur les perspectives
futures de démolition je ne sais pas si
vous avez pied parce que il me pince moi
il me semble que la nature que le
gouvernement oui une émission qui a eu
lieu chez monsieur requier exactement
car si je souhaiterais je pense à madame
je pense à nous tous quand je pense à ce
jeu je pense à ceux qui aujourd'hui son
avis situation précaire parce que au
jour le jour ils ne savent pas ce que
vont devenir leur patrimoine leurs
maisons leurs souvenirs leurs familles
tout ce qu'ils ont construit il ya
beaucoup de gens que dans ces situations
qui ne peuvent plus travailler
vous faites allusion à quel moment de
l'émission si je suis heureux que oui il
ya eu il ya eu quand même un certain
nombre de choses pas seulement
d'ailleurs sur le maintien monsieur qui
faisait messieurs apparus notamment
référence au fait que il faisait le pari
que ces maisons seraient détruites et
plutôt en se gaussant
en rigolant de la situation des
sinistrés donc je l'ensemble l'ensemble
des sinistres a été tout à fait révoltés
du comportement d'un ministre vis-à-vis
de gens qui aujourd'hui souffrent encore
de situation qui trouve totalement
injuste et pour beaucoup de sinistrés il
ya quand même des gens qui ont souffert
par de l'eau par par des dégâts et par
une peur mais aussi beaucoup de gens
aujourd'hui qui se trouvent dans des
situations où leur maison n'a pas été
touchée se trouve potentiellement vesoul
dans leurs choix que c'est moi je pense
très franchement je pense aujourd'hui
pour discuter y compris en heurts avec
des membres du gouvernement qui sont
intéressés que l'ensemble du
gouvernement désormais pas toujours été
le cas et sur la lie que monsieur borloo
avait explicité dans sa dans sa lettre
du 14 ou 15 avril dernier quand même
monsieur borloo sur europe 1 à une
interview disait little aux échelles ou
théorêt s'en sortir sont des maisons
qu'avait caractère gabarit avec jean
perrin kalach oui oui mais oui mais
disons mais là on peut pas bhl la
franchement moi même qui suis bien au
courant du dossier j'avais enfin bon
c'était difficile de 10 parce que
c'était une sorte d' échange rapide
non je peux là dessus je pense pas que
non parce que tous les cop's ya
effectivement un échange très rapide
chez bien entre toujours être
parfaitement maître de celui je cherche
à kiffa personnes mais très honnêtement
je pense que le gouvernement aujourd'hui
est sur cette ligne là et si je le dis
c'est que je me souviens très bien de
des échanges que j'ai eus le soir le
premier ministre nous appeler le soir où
je vous ai rencontrés et où de toute la
journée je me suis décomposer petit
parce que je voyais qu'il y avait quand
même des problèmes je ventile terme ce
portrait le matin jeux le lendemain j'ai
eu un problème en vendée je suis fier
puisque dieu il y avait un problème
pourquoi ouais parce que 1,8 pour abel
goumba oui à quelle heure jean toute
proche de ses sièges en matinée les
choses avaient enfin en tout cas vous en
voudrez et donc j'ai eu le premier
ministre à trois reprises il m'a demandé
mon sentiment au nom de la mission
j'ai même réuni à huis clos en fin de
journée après avoir vu les maires après
avoir vous avoir rencontré on n'est pas
possible on ne peut pas on peut pas
continuer comme ça il ya il faut
infléchir un certain nombre de
dispositions
il m'a rappelé ensuite je lui fais des
propositions il m'a rappelée à deux
reprises il m'a dit qu'il voyait jean
louis borloo le lendemain matin on a
parlé d'un voyage ministériel et c'est
comme ça que les choses se sont
déroulées que kylie a vu monsieur borloo
à 10h30 11h je crois ou à un peu plus
tôt et que ensuite chez borloo est venue
à la rochelle avec benoist apparu
et puis chantal jouanno et new holland
est en hqe il ya eu aussi apparues et
chantal jouanno à la préfecture mais
mais c'est là dessus il a fait la lettre
la lettre a été rédigée cette lettre
elle n'a pas été seulement rédigés par
lui
elle exprime le point de vue du
gouvernement ensuite il ya une
cacophonie d'accord à plusieurs niveaux
et il me semble qu'aujourd'hui on
revient sur la base de
ce texte met en fête enfin on revient
peut-être le projet de loi à l'assemblée
nationale qui est en préparation pour un
vote prévoit dans l'article 2 je crois
que les maisons en zone noire de vente
est détruite dans un délai de deux ans
donc les procédures mais monsieur
monsieur apparu monsieur apparu été très
clair et c'est très clair le
propriétaire de choix à choix mais
excusez moi il n'a pas le choix soit
c'est une vente amiable soit cette liste
propria sion après enquête publique
winamax le mais il n'est pas là il est
le premier dans le périmètre un pardon
le problème est dans le périmètre on est
d'accord mais est-ce que ça c'est
important qu'on se fait bien d'accord
moi je pense que enfin j'exprime
vraiment le le point de vue de la nappe
la mission je pense que quand ya un
risque mortel avéré
vous serez d'accord de faire tous je le
teste qu'en maintenant une question de
ce fait si on n'est pas d'accord
là-dessus d'accord sur rien bon donc je
crois qu'il faut aussi avoir un langage
de vérité les uns avec les autres
moi en tant qu'élu je peux pas tenir une
autre position que celle qui consiste à
dire que caen tient et ailleurs c'est la
loi et donc quand le temps est lui je
suis content d'enfin je dois respecter
les lois qui sont votées peut-être par
d'autres mais maintenant par moi aussi
quand on a un risque
affairé majeur avéré effet un risque
mortel c'est pas raisonnable de laisser
des gens habitaient dans ces zones a
déclaré au caire
excusez moi est-ce qu'à des critères
exacts des quels sont les critères
exacts problèmes de zonage mais quels
sont les critères exacts préfet nous
renvoie mort monsieur le préfet nous
renvoie aux dépérit on nous renvoie aux
prairies de 2004 qui n'a pas été changé
d'ailleurs il n'a pas été modifié sinon
ça aurait fait donc il fait vite mais
moi j'aime moi je moi je pense enfin moi
en tout cas c'est ce que l'on m'a dit
c'est que le jeu le et en ont commandé
région se bat sur cette position là je
pense que il y aura un nouveau périmètre
soumises à enquête publique
je pense qu'il y aura donc un
rétrécissement moi je peux pas en
vouloir au serment le terme vient pas
marc disant resserrement de périmètre à
ce moment là et il y en aura d'autres au
moment de la procédure
dans quel public donc on va aller le
périmètre initial change enfin les pays
il me semble que eelv ont évolué donc
d'après vous savez dans quel sens
monsieur le président il est dans le bon
sens je peins pas pour port des barques
je suis du bouchon je pars pas pour port
des barques parce que je ne parle pas
pour windows et mac
attendez j'essaie j'essaie de donner
deux doses et pour tout le monde
s'exprime à vous excuser moi vous
adresse vous êtes sur ma droite du coup
je ne vois pas comme vous je l'avais le
doigt sur ce sujet là vous mettez le
point sur la question du zonage
on en revient toujours à la compétence
de l'expertisé oui si c'est pour ça
qu'il faut qu'il prenne une des experts
qu'ils aillent encore sur le terrain
qu'en profitent nous d'exister on est
allé sur le terrain donc le xiv et louis
14 et le 15 avril
c'est ce qu'on a dit profitons des mois
qui nous séparent du dépôt de me la mise
à lenquête publics pour qu'ils y ait des
expertises complémentaires pour qu'on
soit je considère que quand on est sûr
de son bon droit on doit pas avoir peur
expliquer et de justifier sa décision ce
qui est justifiable et ce qui est
explicable et de et reçu de façon
beaucoup plus apaisée sereine et
comprises et acceptées
plutôt que de ce qu'ils aient reçu de
façon uniquement autoritaire donc c'est
tout à fait et il est il est tout à fait
affligeant que 100 jours quasiment le
tiers d'une année ça fait 100 jours que
le coq cynthia est passé nous n'ayons
toujours vu aucun expert c'est l'action
dia deux points sur lesquels il va
falloir se battre vite c'est bien sûr je
ne comprends pas que mais je pense que
je ne peux pas penser qu'il n'y ait pas
de délégués à la solidarité en rendait
donc je vais m'en assurer
très vite est géré sur place j'irai sur
place m'ont assuré aussi je vous promets
est par ailleurs le deuxième page
on m'a indiqué et il était convenu qu'il
y ait des expertises des missions
d'experts pour pour les études
complémentaires donc là aussi on
rappellera les engagements à qui de
droit
pardon monsieur attendait parce que oui
je voudrais revenir sur le président sur
un terme qui je crois pourrait faire
consensus général et c'est un terme que
j'avais noté pour le pour le signifier
lors de cette audition c'est le terme
très juste que vous avez employé de
périmètre de solidarité
oui si nous arrivons à ce concept là oui
nous serons d'accord mais pour la faute
sur mer il faut savoir que nous sommes
toujours à la date du 8 avril avec une
zone des zones noires d'une
intransigeance qui n'ont pas bougé d'un
bébé dit pour l'instant ces zones ne
repose sur aucun fondement juridique
ce ne sont que des zones on les appelle
des zones d'acquisition amiable parce
que ça nous on pense que c'est c'est pas
une habileté et sémantique la zone
d'acquisition amiable c'est sait ce que
ça veut dire finalement et et rien
d'autre aujourd'hui donc ces périmètres
là n'ont pas de valeur juridique si ce
n'est qu' elle ouvre ce droit il faut
qu'on en parle aussi là
de france domaine on n'y en a pas encore
trop parler mais elle ouvre un droit
mais au delà de droits qu'elles ouvrent
elles n'ont pas de fondement juridique
particulier mais la décision du tribunal
de jeu pas si vous l'avez j'imagine de
poitiers là dessus est assez clair sauf
qu'il y a des conséquences sur sur le
vécu des gens je rebondis sur les
remarques de nos amis de fouras les gens
se sentent victimes d'une grande
injustice et y remarque des injustices
de traitement du côté charente maritime
du côté vendée ils disent pourquoi les
uns pourquoi pas les autres etc
je je c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas
expliquer les décisions je peux me tenir
je peux vous citer des cas manifestes
d'injustice le quartier par quartier rue
paru sur prenons par exemple la la la la
la cuvette de la faute-sur-mer
nous nous battons pas contre la nous ne
défendons pas l'indéfendable
je puis vous présenter si vous deviez
faire une cartographie ou qui représente
la position de nos adhérents ceux qui
veulent partir ceux qui veulent rester
c'est clair cette cartographie c'est une
cartographie de bon sens elle dit que là
où les adhérents ont été massivement
touchés massivement inondées et là où il
ya eu des victimes
les gens en veulent partir mais là où le
débat est ouvert et on vient pas laisser
passer une seule maison dans la cuve est
ici c'est que là c'est là où il y a eu
peu d'eau ou pas d'eau les gens veulent
rester je puis vous donner les chiffres
monsieur le président 27 / sur les ce
sur la sueur l'enquète offrit deux sur
la faute auprès de nos de nos sinistres
et 27% des maisons qui sont en zone
noire n'ont pas eu d'eau 48% des maisons
ont eu moins de 50 50 cm d'eau et 70%
moins d'un mètre d'eau je puis vous
donner des noms que vous connaissez
aussi bien que moi au moins puisque vous
êtes vendéen monsieur le président sur
la zone de la faute si je vous parle du
band démarche mais qui n'a pas eu non si
je vous parle de du boulevard du lait
côté cimetière qui n'a pas eu d eau qui
se sont incompréhensibles en zone noire
si je vous parle du cheval n 2
des relais de mer qui ne se trouve pas à
redire à ce jour ces zones noires
ces zones noires pour moi ne repose pas
sur une base juridique
elles n'ont pas de base juridique elle
ouvre un droit
voilà et donc je il faut que après des
expertises de terrain et bien il y ait
de nouveau périmètre qui soient soumises
à enquête publique
ce sont mes de toute façon quel est
l'intérêt y compris de 2,2 de l'état si
le dossier d'enquêté publique est faible
et fragile ça ses fils usher a alors
filmé mais en longueur c'est vrai et on
userait c'est ça le problème
donc même bien sûr c'est ça le problème
c'est le manque donc tout le monde sera
perdant
oui mais l'état aussi finalement puisque
tout sera alors l'état évidemment il n'a
pas de oui madame
si vous pouvez appuyer je crois avant le
thon rouge alors moi je suis vilain
petit canard
parce que j'ai 62 ans et je veux rentrer
chez moi je suis derrière la cuve est un
vaisseau son dos oui bien sûr que si je
veux rentrer chez moi je n'ai pas des
scènes maison de plain pied
je m'en suis sorti parce que j'avais un
grenier je suis pas idiote je vais
construire deux restent constamment au
mans mais vous êtes dans la cuvette
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave aux
jambes
alors du reste mon contrat d'assurance
prévoient que si la loi disait qu'il
fallait monter un étage mon l'assurance
ne le payent sept étages c'est dans mon
contrat d'assurance donc bien sûr que si
je restais je ferai tout pour
pour pouvoir au cas où un jour et encore
un grand vent de sud qui reviennent qui
est une grande marée qui est tous les
éléments qu'ils soient de la même côté
parce que c'est quand même arrivé qu'une
seule fois que ça se passe de ce côté là
c'est quand même une tornade on ne nous
a pas prévenus
on abordera après j'espère parce que
c'est quand même bien là un ménage et
110 c'est qu'on ne disait pas prévenu je
comprends ce que je veux dire juste mais
ça vous paraît aberrant bien sûr il dans
notre nom
madame je connais parfaitement là je
vais vous dire moi ça fait rage et j'y
suis bien moins que ça fait plus de 40
ans que j'habite la même commune rurale
j'ai déménagé de killer donc
l'attachement à mon truc je sais ce que
c'est donc je peux critiquer ce que moi
je ressens aussi bon donc simplement je
me dis pensez aussi parce qu'on vieillit
tous penser au jour où évidemment on a
on n'a pas la prestance et ceara pour
grimper pour voilà c'est tout après
essai
vous êtes le seul juge c'est pas moi qui
vais vous dire le jour je vais sentir en
danger quand je fais quelque chose je le
fais à fond
si je me sentais un danger un jour je
partirai ça c'est clair
si je n'avais plus la capacité pense que
c'est le mans serait de toute façon à
mes enfants s'ils avaient pu la tête
pour le faire on sait jamais c'est
effectivement de les forcer à le faire
mais là on n'en est pas là aujourd'hui
c'est que je ne suis pas la seule
je suis dans le lotissement du virely
nord ou à 95%
ce sont des habitations principales
c'est lequel sait rien ce sport juste de
port le port de plaisance ah oui il ya
95% si vous voulez il y en a qui
voulaient rester ceux qui ont peur ils
ont eu peur hein
on a fait du reste des gros chèques de
vente à bourg battant avec la télévision
est haute
des gens très simples qui voulait pas de
télévision pour l'heure pour leur dire
ça y est ils ont une fortune
bon la fortune n'est pas terrible à
entre nous soit dit mais messi vous
les bons je suis le vilain petit canard
aujourd'hui puisque j'ai de l'eau et je
fais pas partie de ces soixante dix et
quarante huit autres mais je ne suis pas
la seule ce sont des habitations
principales mais par contre c'est vrai
que tous les gens qui resterait et pour
le coup on n'avait pas le droit avant on
construira un étage ça c'est clair mais
oui mes récits poèmes c'est le président
moi je voulais revenir sur les
expertises avant l'anc est pas la balade
et ip je suis d'accord bon ce qui est
défendable sera défendu ce qui n'est pas
défendable comme vous disiez tout à
l'heure mais il faut vraiment que ça
serait une vraie expertise we con comme
je vous le disais tout à l'heure c'est
que l'on ne fait pas que constater les
hauteurs d'eau il faut aussi se demander
pourquoi on t'aidera l'état une
expertise c'est ça on les attaque droit
et le dire que si les expertises sont
fragiles voilà donc il n'y a aucun
intérêt je trouve surtout pas pour les
sinistrés et à mon avis non plus pour
l'état a conservé une fragilité dans
dans les périmètres
oui bien sûr mon système une possibilité
c'est qu'il ya encore des terrains sont
la faute sur mer que le maire dispose de
ces terrains ce qui est loin d'être le
cas parce qu'ils sont privés et on en
reparlera en petit comité je ne peux pas
aujourd'hui même affirme là dessus si
vous voulez qu'ils me disent que bon bah
voilà on vous laisse la possibilité de
prendre tes des terrains sur la
faute-sur-mer de pouvoir vous placez là
après moi ma vie elle est là bas ma
retraite elle était là-bas ont marre et
commandant de marine marchande s'ils
avaient plus penser à un moment
quelconque qu'il était en danger
on a eu notre maison serait parti le
souci aujourd'hui est là je suis
vraiment mordu là dessus si vous voulez
je ne cèderai pas c'est que moi j'avais
la possibilité sa maman avait la
possibilité son compagnon ayant une
maison à l'aiguillon
le monsieur qui a perdu ses deux enfants
sa femme et sa maman avait aussi la
possibilité de rentrer dans d'autres
maisons les gens on pouvait les sauver
peut-être que c'était pas facile mais en
tout cas il restait beaucoup d'heures
je ne citerai pas de noms parce que vous
savez qu'il ya des procès que nous avons
lancée
mais quand j'ai entendu dire en vous
regardant la commission sénatoriale qu'à
17h30
on avait on savait et bien à 17h30 moi
chanter de chez le notaire où j'avais
signé quelque chose et je pouvais
effectivement rentré chez moi à la
roche-sur-yon
comment on a disposé de ma vie comment
on a disposé de la vie de sam hancock et
de mépris ce que ce qu'on nous a dit je
on a répété ce que météo france nous a
dit c'est que les premiers bulletins
avaient été acheminés entre je pu
choisir vous dites c'est que 17 ans j'ai
vu sur la commission sénatoriale comesa
versus préfère c'est lui qu'il est
jaloux il c'est ça ben voilà donc c'est
pas c'est pas moi qui l'affirmé je sais
pas
les questions à poser à lisieux au
niveau de la météo ça a été annoncé en
rouge pour la vendée la
charente-maritime à 16 heures météo et
le préfet anne en laissant les systèmes
d' alerte
le préfet de charente-maritime sur le
site de
de la préfecture inviter les gens à
rester chez eux et surtout ne pas sortir
alors même que le principe même dans des
zones sûres mais ça c'était avant d'un
principe d'évacuation ambition que de
rester chez soi shine est preque donc on
va alors peut-être que bien sûr le doyen
ville les gens connaissent les cieux
chez eux c'est très clair de toute façon
le risque zéro n'existe pas suivant le
principe répond non non mais prenez
votre voiture le matin vous acceptez le
risque nous nous nous je vous dis aussi
vain on va travailler protection parce
que là on parle zones noires
d'évacuation de destruction et je
voudrais terminer pour reparler de
protection s'il pleut l'état pourrait
envisager de faire des diffère des
protections droits réservés la vigne en
parler parce que je ne nous a enfin
dossier technique nous avons remis en
fait on peut très bien sécurisé un petit
village avec peu de choses le sécuriser
l'eau arrive la nuit qu'est ce qui se
passe la lumière s'éteint donc il
faudrait peut-être des petites applique
n'est ce pas qui permette ne pas
s'affoler il faut un refuge il faut un
petit pc avec les téléphones aux
moustaches qui où et quand à la personne
et la situation difficile avec un pc de
sécurité j'ai fini d'avoir une petite
pièce pourrait pour pouvoir re récupérer
et des jambes et aussi bien pour lui que
pour le feu il faut il faut peu de
choses il faut une sirène extérieure
n'est ce pas bon il faut évidemment ça
va avec pour nous à boyardville la
réfection des digues l'herbe a dit que
nous on a des berges
d'aucuns diluerait les petits murets com
com arrive tout comme à la rochelle
c'est pas grand chose ça coûte pas cher
et pourquoi va-t-on ne
outre les charentes atx et des morts et
ça on n'a pas d'interlocuteur on ne peut
pas proposer on ne peut pas en discuter
voilà on aimerait bien en discuter
attendez mal vous êtes j'essaie de que
chacun puisse exprimer
pour revenir sur la problématique de
l'organisation des secours en prévention
ou le sur le sur l'événement même c'est
vrai que l'on se pose des questions et
par le biais je dirais de plaintes en
faisant appel aux procédures que notre
pays offre évidemment nous demandons des
explications sur ce qui s'est passé et
ce qui aurait dû être fait pour que en
effet les victimes elles soient pas
démago rico mon nom on revient de c'est
pour ça est ce qui vous dit il faut pas
les protections mais je vous parlais
beaucoup plus que protection on revient
on est passé on a passé quelques jours
au long de la semaine dernière on a
énormément à apprendre leur langue et
franchement franchement quand on s'y
rend on va recevoir une délégation du
japon on est soucieux quand même de
l'argent public et la semaine prochaine
on recevra donc une délégation du japon
qui a une culture du risque alors là
c'est sismique
hollande c'est de la submersion marine
ou des inondations fluviales et de
rivières mais nous on l'a constaté des
défaillances à tous les niveaux au
niveau de la prévision il faut qu'on ait
des modèles de prévision qui soit pas
seulement une surcote au large il faut
des choses beaucoup plus fine
il faut des alertes qui soit pas
seulement des sms etc il faut des vrais
cellule pour qu' on puisse avoir
on puisse savoir que les élus puissent
avoir un dialogue avec des gens
compétents qui vendit attention une
surcote d'un mètre
ça peut se traduire chez vous par par
tel niveau d'inondation
les élus chantent de geron d'hier ont
reçu pour la seule année 2009
parce que je sais que c'est un sport
national de tirer sur les élus mais ils
peuvent avoir des responsabilités
parfois mais mais ils ont reçu entre 30
et 50 bulletins d'alerté trop d' alerte
tout ça vient quand on crie au loup tous
les toutes les 30 ou 50 ça veut dire que
quand il ya 50 il ya 52 semaines
ça veut dire qu'en moyenne il ya dix
semaines peut-être via palettes et des
semaines il a deux ou trois et élise
alerte ils comprennent pas une surcote
en lice a pas donc ça il faut le revoir
pour qu' il puisse y avoir des mesures
d'évacuation et notamment des plans
communaux de sauvegarde bon kantien ppr
il faut un plan communal de sauvegarde
impérativement et c est jusqu alors
la prévision la prévention jusqu'à la
protection les digues
on a constaté une augmentation du niveau
de la mer une augmentation du niveau de
la mer ça veut dire des risques accrus
dans le temps et dans le les hollandais
de mules ont des très clairement une
augmentation de cinquante centimètres du
niveau de la mer il en eût eu depuis
1840 centimes d'augmentation du niveau
de la mer eh bien ça veut dire que un
événement qui avait une occurrence
centrale
c'est un événement corps à une
occurrence décennale d'accord donc il ya
beaucoup de choses à changer en france
est ce qu'on va nous essayer de dire
c'est que moi j'espère ils ont eu un
événement fondateur pour eux qui était
celui de 1953
un mille huit cent cinquante cinq ou six
morts bon ils ont fait un plan delta la
moche que je souhaiterais pour que les
morts ne soient pas morts pour rien si
j'ose dire c'est que ce soit un
événement qui permettent en france
d'éviter d'autres drames et d'éviter
d'autres drames ça veut dire revoir
profondément tous nos systèmes parce que
il ya une chaîne de responsabilités et
surtout parce que on n'a pas de culture
du risque
à tous ces niveaux prévisions prévention
et protection
allez-y
alors vous vous dites qu'il ya souvent
des bulletins dallaire d'un mois j'ai vu
celui de 17 heures environ du samedi 27
il était vraiment alarmant et j'ai eu
c'est même la sous préfète qui me l'a
montré vraiment j'arrive pas à
comprendre comment personne n'appelle
réagir ma maman et allait fermer ses
volets à trois kilomètres de chez elle
elle aurait pu dormir
on m'a dit oui mais il n'y avait pas de
plan de prévention à cause de la non
mise en place du ppr y donc il y avait
pas de plan d'évacuation on n'aurait pas
pu évacuer tout le monde il y avait
presque personne dans le quartier en
trois maisons en faisant trente mètres
il ya sept morts sur dix personnes
présentes 70%
est ce que je veux dire un peu c'est que
quand ray 3 ti 20 quand vous lisez
qu'effectivement une alerte avant qu'un
élément produisent et quand il s'est
produit
vous n'y mettez pas le même sens il
sollicite un oui mais savait s'il était
suffisamment explicite il ya beaucoup de
maires à y regarder on parle de on va
pas parler de la vente et on ne peut pas
parler à chaud maritime la gironde
ils ont su de zeller une alerte devant
une alerte inondations lé alertes
d'inondations certains maires ont cru
que c'était la confirmation d'alerté
vent c'est bien qu'il ya un problème il
faut pas que on laisse si vous voulez
une marge d'incertitude est peut-être
que certains auraient dû ne pas se
tromper mais de toute façon il ya eu un
problème
donc il faut bien chercher quelque part
pour pas que ça se reproduise parce que
sinon il y aura des gens qui ne
comprendront pas ce qu'une surcote veut
dire à terre donc il faut qu'on rend il
faut qu'on mette des dispositifs en
place pour dire une surcote
ça veut dire telle innovation et à
partir de là il ya des évacuations il ya
toute une chaîne qui se met en prendrait
ce que je veux pas voyez je veux pas
minimiser les choses mais je veux pas
qu'on dise
écoutez tout était parfait tout était
déjà dit et les gens auraient dû agir
non si les gens n'ont pas agi c'est
parce qu'il y avait des imperfections
pas seulement chez les gens dans les
processus dans les procédures dans dans
les rédactions et moi partout quand on
s'est déplacés et pas seulement
mais en france on nous dit on un vrai
problème et en l'homme on nous dit aussi
en lan on reçoit les gens reçoivent
l'alertent et bien à chaque fois il ya
une conversation d'une personne de
l'état de la province avec le maire pour
expliquer pour expliciter la leyre vous
savez les maires vous en trouverez qui
sont ingénieurs qui sont agriculteurs ja
tout bon chacun réagit avec sont donc il
faut c'est cette marge d'incertitudes
qu'il faut qu'on réduise et ça les
procédures nous permettent doit vous
permettre de réduire cette marge
d'incertitude
c'est très important pour l'avenir voyez
ce que je veux dire mais est-ce que vous
pouvez m'affirmer excusez moi après je
suis partie prenante de ceux qui veulent
sauver leur maison et mais je voudrais
juste savoir si au moins il n'y aura
aucune entrave pour qu'on n'arrive à
comprendre à je peux vous assuré
j'espère parce que j'ai eu un entretien
bas notamment avec un gendarme qui m'a
dit il ya des faits mais c'est
juridiquement comment est ce qu'on va
pouvoir
ça va pouvoir être interprétée et
j'espère qu'il aura aucune entrave et
que la sortie d'un tribunal je serais
pas en train de pleurer parce que parce
que j'aurais pas de réponse franchement
sur une catastrophe sur un drame comme
celui ci je vois pas quelle pression la
justice pourrait subir pour entraver son
hub recours quand même parce que la
justice d'abord je lui fais confiance
là j'espère et celui qui se risqueraient
à ce genre de choses prendraient comme
des gros risques et surtout le risque
devrait être entendu bien entendu par la
justice parce qu'on est quand même dans
un état de droit donc je crois que
là-dessus je sais que bon il ya aussi
l'idée d'un doute qu'ils répandu souvent
sur le processus des choses très
franchement pas un instant j'imagine ce
genre de situation du port des barques
en temps débarque avec les parents oui
il faudrait juste intervenir et rebondit
un petit peu sur la sphère de ce
personne qui a loué un mètre soixante
comment pensez vous que vont réagir les
compagnies d'assurance
quand les personnes ne vont avoir eu des
hauteurs d'eau conséquentes
est ce que les compagnies d'assurance
vont continuer à assurer ces personnes
parce qu'on a le cas aussi bon départ je
reviens je suis surpris par les gens qui
ont eu 80 cm ou un maître qui ont eu des
dégâts considérables
comment vont réagir les assurances dans
le futur est ce que vous pensez qu'il va
y avoir un appui de la commission aussi
pour justement essayer de travailler ce
sujet au niveau de l'assurance si je
peux me permettre
si je sors de la zone noire mon
assurance m'assure je suis passé à
lhassa lotissement on est à une
topographie entre 3 et 5 m si vous
regardez sur internet la topographie
donc je suis juste derrière l'accueil ac
était à 0 2 ce que faut reconnaître l
état zéro lag fait elle à 0 pas bon
la loose heroes elle est universelle moi
je suis à 3 m alors c'est vrai que c'est
un peu complexe parce que finalement
j'ai été sur protégé par de très gros
mur que je que j'ai fait tous les ans
qui sont des murs je réponds à ma sur la
collaborateur me me dis qu'il ya une
obligation d'assurance si jamais il ya
un souci ya un bureau central que vous
pouvez saisir
en revanche le tarif l tard et autre
jour il n'y a pas de risque at
obligations en la matière il faut sortir
de la zone noire beaucoup de silences
erreur de faire une différenciation au
cas par cas en zone par zone plutôt que
d'avoir un tarif national
mais bon mais en tout état de cause il
ya obligation d'assurance qui est
contracté le sida rail suis travail pour
essayer de relire effectivement cette
idée de d'assurance de risée de
prévention quand je reviens de seconde
sur ce que vous disiez sur ce que vous
avez vu dans nos dans nos pays voisins
nordiques et sur les principes
d'évacuation est ce que vous avez pu
récupérer des méthodologies qu'on
pourrait soumettre à nos sacs non je
vais vous dire je vais vous dire parce
que ça fait j'en suis je suis jeune j'ai
géré 91 on en a mieux que ça qu'une
méthodologie on a quelqu'un qui est un
qui est un ingénieur qu'à une culture de
la défense contre la mer qui est
extraordinaire qui vient régulièrement
en france dont l'épousé fontenaisienne
et qui a perdu deux membres de sa
famille en vendée je peux vous assurer
que il a trait à coeur de comprendre des
choses il
il est d'ailleurs avec le service son
service est un fonctionnaire
ils sont en train aujourd'hui de rédiger
un hammam ti libre sur les leçons que
les pays bas peuvent irriter xynthia est
évident que ce document vous dire que je
me le procure ray de même que je lui
soumettrai un certain nombre de choses
d'excéder que ça sortira y compris
d'ailleurs sur les sur le plan digues
m'aimait bien entendu si nous sommes
aller là bas c'est pour essayer
d'aborder le sont parce que c'est quand
même des gens c'est pas pour rien qu'on
a une dictée hollandais dans le sud
vendée
c'est pas pour rien que sur noirmoutier
on a une 10 qui porte le nom de jacob ça
ne sais pas
il s'appelle c'est peu dire retailleau
un des papas mamans vendée elle porte un
nom néerlandais c'est oui vous vous
abordez justement le problème des
méthodes de prévention quelque part
d'aménagement du territoire de manière à
ce que les les conséquences d'une
tempête telle que l'on a connu ce repas
aussi dévastatrice donc dans le
processus que l'état a mis en mouvement
de zones de solidarité de zones noires
et autres on a quand même compris que il
était quand même aussi important de voir
en quoi les indemnisations qu'ils
pouvaient être proposés étaient moins
coûteuse que des remédiations des
entretiens d'idées sur un des parades
qui pourrait permettre de maintenir les
zones cno pas les zones pardon des
habitations dans certaines zones
alors on est bien d'accord effectivement
les conditions actuelles et la
responsabilité des hommes virait
l'encensent jurés de prendre en
considération les dangers faut qu'on a
pas de protester actuellement quelques c
qu'est ce que ça existe la dangerosité
de certains vieux mais on peut se poser
de la question de savoir comment la
protection de celles y aurait pu être
prise en compte et est finalement
n'aurait pas coûté aussi cher que
certaines procédures d'analysé
non mais la protection sociale un débat
et c'est un point sur lequel on ya
travaillé d'ailleurs tout à l'heure on
avait la réunion la réunion de la
commission en début d'après midi donc on
en a largement parlé moi j'ai attiré
votre attention sur le chômage aux
présidents du conseil d'état de 99 enfin
pour vous les cabinets qui vous suivent
le savent bien
le l'a77 jurisprudence elle exprime une
idée qu'on n'est jamais sûr totalement
d'efficacité une protection
c'est une jurisprudence 4,99
elle est importante j'espère que mais
j'en suis certain que les cabinets
d'avocats qui vous suivent selon lepoint
thellend le repérer et donc si vous
voulez voilà c'est faux
la commune la question de la protection
elle est fondamentale mais en même temps
il faut la lire notamment sur point
juridique avec et pour ce que vous
imaginez faire faut la lire avec 7
c'est pas juste parler moi même je
jouais a juste posé une question parce
que je sais que les prochains les
prochaines personnes sont sont ici pour
l'audition l'indemnisation donc partout
les les cas que qui sont venus à moi
tous me disent que l'organisation est
pas forcément surestimer ni rapide et
juste
en tout cas par un non alors allez-y
qu'elle quels sont vos expériences alors
allez-y sur les écouter nous pour les
domaines déjà nous la loi personne avait
contacté les domaines c'est là c'est là
que la municipalité qui a pris rendez
vous avec les domaines pour que nos
biens soit estimé donc mais ça ça vous
oblige à rien s'il vous pouvez services
aux usa rien mais la démo est pas non
non vous pouvez non ça joue confirmant
vous pouvez évaluer et iliad et je
connais des gens qui évalue sans pour
autant ça monsieur monsieur a élu
monsieur apparu justement monsieur après
même enregistrement 8000 et de
l'innovation ni estimations ces dix
personnes qui votent l'ordre est
d'ailleurs monsieur pour lula dans deux
mois ça dans cette enceinte
il ya effectivement des gens qui veulent
vendre et faut respecter leur volonté
il ya des gens qui souhaitent avoir la
base d'une estimation seulement dans le
courrier des domaines c'est bien
spécifié que
dans le cahier domaine c est spécifié
que les gens qui ont demandé
l'estimation c'est des gens qui ont
souhaité quitter leur maison pour ceux
qui ont émis le souhait de quitter leurs
maisons alors que nous on n'a jamais eu
un super en oscillation ça n'engage à
rien le conteur non à confessionnal je
le dis mais si je voulais après j'aurai
revenir une seconde après sur la juste
le zonage le manque de considération
oui par rapport aux sinistrés rapidement
parce que quand même on n'a toujours
aucun document je le répète aucun
document et on y laisse des gens libres
à eux d'interpréter les différentes
déclarations faites par les médias sont
dans l'incertitude ça fait trois mois
qu'on ne savent pas quoi penser qu'ils
peuvent pas vivre et les voyants en face
leurs voisins c'est sûr ils ont été
sifflés par la même tempête mais qui eux
peuvent continuer à vivre normalement
donc c'est dur à comprendre
on attendait juste j'ai le souci
d'organiser la discussion autour de ce
thème parce qu'après on n'arrive pas
quand on est beaucoup
l'ornais sur le thème de l'indemnisation
pour l'instant vous voulez interdir sur
ce thème
bon après ça sera vous après d'accord on
va aller dialysés monsieur et et si vous
pouvez être bref à souligner que je vais
pas partir est ce que j'accepte ou non
l'offre des domaines or il faudrait que
les sinistrés qui sont dans ce
questionnement là puissent se décider en
connaissance de tous les éléments
or il y à un élément qu'ils ne
connaissent pas c'est le ppdri les
domaines font des offres qui eux sont
valables pour trois mois
sauf erreur de ma part or les ppr y vont
être connu on ne sait pas dans six mois
dans un an il faudrait que les domaines
puisse étendre leur délai de réflexion
aux sinistrés lorsque l'épée périt
seront connus à ce moment là des
sinistrés pourront peser le pour et le
contre les avantages et les
inconvénients des ppdri et comme nous le
disions tout à l'heure
les gens sont de bon sens et si certains
voulaient absolument quand ce qu ont
conservé leurs maisons malgré un péril
vis-à-vis de leur vie peut-être qu'à ce
moment là ils trouveraient des éléments
objectifs pour dire ben finalement non
je préfère que ma famille ne soient pas
en danger je pars ou alors concernant
que perry qui classerait leur zone
leur leur maison dans dans un périmètre
où il n'y aurait pas de péril imminent
voilà que cela donc que les domaines
puisse allant chez leurs délais de
réflexion et que le délai de réflexion
coïncide avec la sortie la publication
des pprt comme chez max saisissez merci
le président concernant l'évaluation des
domaines je pense qu'il faut distinguer
les personnes qui souhaitent être
indemnisé des personnes qui le
souhaitent pas pour les personnes qui
souhaitent être indemnisés pour qui
concerne charron je peux vous dire que
le travail est bien fait par france
domaine à part quelques évaluations qui
sont à reconsidérer et quand on le
demande c'est reconsidérée donc je pense
que je peux dire au nom des sinistrés de
charron que le travail de france domaine
est bien correct et que l'évaluation est
au dessus de l'évaluation des notaires
donc c'est un aspect positif de cette
situation catastrophique pour ce qui
concerne les personnes qui font part par
peur par crainte de tout perdre
faire des évaluations par france domaine
on en revient à la question initiale
principal est inacceptable du zonage
donc retour à la case départ ce que nous
demandons depuis le début nous
continuons nous le demandons de le
demander nous espérons que nous serons
entendus sur ce sujet qui est
inacceptable c'est le deuxième point
et puis pour ce qui concerne les
évaluations pour pour charron cela
génère
d une question fondamentale de
relogement à savoir que ces personnes
qui ne sont plus logés depuis 100 jours
aujourd'hui souhaitent se reloger le
plus rapidement possible et elles vont
percevoir les établissements publics
elles vont percevoir des indemnités et
non pas d'espoir de se reloger sur
charron aujourd'hui parce qu'on n'a rien
à leur proposer
à part l'intention du maire de faire des
rachats de terrains en zone non
inondable qui peuvent être transformés
en terrains constructibles par
l'établissement public foncier régional
et cet établissement est une structure
compétente mais très lourde et très
lente à démarrer
on a mis plus d'un mois a signé la
convention qui aurait pu être signé
rapidement
on n'a pas encore contacté un seul
propriétaire foncier
nous sommes dans l'urgence aujourd'hui
est excusez moi de l'illustration mais
j'ai bien peur que les pompiers arrivent
après la fin de l' incendie à dire qu'on
aura acquis qui rit qui présidait ce que
c'est un établissement public ancien
état régional régional qui est original
et il est pas il est pré départ qui par
le premier vice président du conseil
régional monsieur pierre monsieur m'a
guère de régionale d'après l'accord
premier vice président du conseil
régional
il est composé genre j'ai demandé à le
rencontrer et en fait c'est très lent
c'est très lent rencontré à prendre des
rendez-vous est en fait je crois qu'ils
n'ont parmi les 31 élus 1 par des élus
locaux 1 mais parmi les 31 élus qui
composent le conseil d'administration
très peu ont conscience de l'urgence de
la très grande urgence de la situation
attendez monsieur on est toujours dans
les domaines moi je voudrais revenir
surtout au niveau du social et de la
façon dont c'est fait parce que vous
savez je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
qui avait déjà en mana
mais là ils sont en train de mal à me
rendre malade les associations et en
l'occurrence la literie c'est peut-être
pour ça que marie olivia rocca n'est pas
présente aujourd'hui des gens dans la
zone noire on demandait aux domaines
pour expertise et leur maison pardon
mais le bouche à oreille ça fonctionne
pas mal et quand les sommes promis ont
été annoncés pour des petites
maisonnettes ou être comme ça les
domaines sont intervenus et ont regagné
du terrain
tant et si bien qu'ils ont été demandés
aux gens de l'association du conseil
d'administration et ils ont pratiquement
doublé la valeur de leur maison
donc ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui de
l'association des traits n'existe
presque plus et moi je trouve que c'est
grave padrona alors expertise ce matin
10 juin de ma maison par le domaine par
les domaines tout s'est bien passé
par contre une information de dernière
minute les personnes qui sont en
résidence secondaire donc auront un an
après la tenue tarrier pour racheter
quelque chose sinon ils auront 27 % de
plus-value
s'ils ne veulent pas acheter et ça c'est
ce matin l'information des domaines oui
cette information je l'avais pointe et
donc en cinquante mille et bien quand on
enlève 67 9% à s'excuser
ben ça ne me semble j'ai eu
l'information expert comptable il ya
quelque temps qu'il ya une maison voilà
si si j'ai eu
le jeu la confirme il dispose d'un
dispositif juridique qui existe pour les
résineux pas de terrain de plus à lui
voilà voilà la vivacité je ne retrouve
pas terrain voilà je suis allé à charge
seul à la tranche je me retrouvais dans
des conditions complètement différentes
de ce que je vivais avant oui voilà la
difficulté je sais je ne retrouvais on
l'a pointé sait qu'on ne pourra pas pour
faire en sorte que les maires préempter
les terrains résistent qui ne sont pas
dans les halls et ça c'est aussi un
travail alors qu'on doit faire avec les
styles en politique c'est parce que
c'est leur boulot là c'est vrai est clé
pour essayer d'aller pour essayer
d'aller très très vite pour mobiliser du
terrain lui de possibles pour permettre
à des gens qui veulent partir pas loin
il restait pratiquement sur place et
c'est l'intérêt decogalerie terrain il
n'ya pas toujours des terrains il ya des
terrains à mayenne d'acceuillir est
aujourd'hui terrain on nous donne au
moins les terrains qui règne dans les
hanches et les rebelles
la nature est là c'est bien ça nous
exproprier eh bien on va exproprier les
gens qui ont été rasés que c'est à cette
tâche que je vous propose c'est on a les
27% voilà une toute petite chose il ya
deux barrages qui était fermée le jour
de la tempête je sais pas si vous êtes
informés il se trouve juste là où il ya
les ordures voilà et le courant revenait
au site après les domaines d'après
plusieurs personnes les plus le courant
venait de ce côté là je suis allée avec
ma petite valise voir le monsieur qui
s'occupe de ça il est payé par la vallée
du lait je lui ai posé la question
est-ce que vous avez ouvert les barrages
qui vous donne lors c'est la vallée du
lait ou pas non non non bien sûr que non
je suis là je suis là pour faire mon
travail c'est de laisser les barrages
vous avez ouvert
bien sûr que non j'aurais noyer les
champs madame pour la conclusion
je voudrais juste parler pour les
domaines donc moi je voudrais pouvoir
faire mon deuil en paix c'est à dire
régler tous les problèmes matériels donc
ce soit les papiers la maison et voilà
pouvoir être tranquille
les domaines sont venus chez moi sein
chez ma maman qui était résidente
principale personne décédée le 5 mai et
j'attends toujours une réponse
chaque jour je guette a recommandé et à
moins qu'il soit venu ce matin j'étais
dans le train je n'ai toujours pas de
réponse je voudrais l'audition du camp
le 5 mai les domaines donc géré
l'évaluation
oui bon on va coûter le 5 mai on est
aujourd'hui le 10 juin et je n'ai rien 5
mai bal à écouter je vous propose que on
va on appelle on appelle les domaines au
ministère du budget sera peut-être pas
ce soir mais demain matin vous le direz
vous allez laissez vous allez laisser
votre numéro de téléphone à mehdi et et
mehdi vous rappelle dès demain vous
tiendrai informé pad quelqu'un a fait
expertiser sa maison les médias viennent
et dans dix jours et là la réponse du
domaine parce que les médias sont là et
en plus c'est quelqu'un qu'on connaît
bien
super bien expertisé et l'été les médias
lui ont téléphoné en même temps et lui
pour lui ce sera toujours non les infos
qui me sont remontés mois en général de
gens du terrain si c'est que en règle
vraiment le travail de france domaine
est un travail rapide qui cerne les
indemnisations d'assez près ça a été
vraiment un écho que j'ai pu constater
assez général un point avec des gens
très divers
monsieur le président à un désir
monsieur le président les évaluations
qui ont été faites d'oléron sont
extrêmement rapides auront été fait très
rapidement et sont extrêmement
alléchante extrêmement un chien
en tout cas ces propos nous c'est
extrêmement alléchant alors si les
commissaires enquêteurs dont vous
parlais tout à l'heure qui sont des
experts n'osent pas espérons qu sur les
expertes de moi qui pourront modifier
des zones lolo parle au lotissement pour
le traitement au cas par cas pour leur
travail rapidement ça peut bon on peut
peut-être évité la catastrophe
positionnement d'un an
vous allez avoir un gruyère parce que
les gens évidemment accepte les
propositions qui sont très pressante
très pressante une pression énorme des
des domaines ensuite ça fera boule de
neige
n'est ce pas excusez du 5000 m excuser
moi j'espère le problème juste un
exemple en ce qui concerne des domaines
bien qu'on vais pas partir et qu'on à
contester le zonage pour notre domicile
on a en a on s'est renseigné auprès des
agences immobilières on a la possibilité
de racheter un bien terrain deux fois
plus petit maison plus petite est en
plus un terrain qui a eu plus d'un mètre
d'eau qui en vente normal qui n'est pas
sonné pour vous dire qu'on peut être
indemnisés pour quitter sa maison on a
eu 50 40 60 centimètres d'eau pour
pouvoir acheter une maison avec l'argent
du voilà qui a eu plus d'un mètre d'eau
donc je veux dire à quel point c'est un
goéland et cancon bien des choses comme
ça on ne peut pas comprendre ne peut pas
accepter un côté vraiment il faut pas
vraiment chaud c'est par respect
j'espère qu'ils comprendront parce que
on est dans des situations douloureuses
donc je m'en excuse par avance mais il
faut qu'on conclue
je vous remercie encore une fois d'être
venu on va donc pour des réponses
individuelles pour ce qui concerne le
délégué à la solidarité pour qui le
concerne les expertises complémentaires
on va essayer à nouveau de menthe au
créneau pour que l'on puisse être
entendu voilà merci
c'est la fin de cette audition pour la
revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr merci de votre fidélité
et à très bientôt sur notre antenne